reg let me start with steph curry with
what you saw didn't look a hundred
percent but I do give Cleveland a lot of
credit for playing that pick-and-roll
extremely well and forcing him to go
even deeper but Steph Curry got
something going on here you think I do
and we've been talking about it for the
last you know three or four weeks I
never felt that he was right after the
ankle in the injury and then it came out
something was wrong with his shoulder
but I'm not going to make excuses he
laced them up he played seven games I'm
assuming you're one hundred percent so
I'm not going to take anything away from
the cavs they they earned this lebron
and company they earned this beam down
3-1 and having to win two of the three
games in a building where the team with
the best record a historic record had
only lost once during the regular season
they earn this so did steph look right
no Willie probably needs surgery that
will never hear about perhaps but give
all the credit to the cavs they earn
this they flip the script and understood
that he's heard he's banged up whatever
defensively he's not able to check
LeBron or Kyrie or JR smith they were
posting JR smith on him they understood
we are going at him and either you guys
are going to help and that's going to
unleash our three-point shooting or
we're going to go right through and
that's what they did all right as I
mentioned earlier that LeBron could
leave now if he wanted two he's given
the city of title yes right yes I don't
I now would not be surprised and I don't
think we'll get the backlash of the
decision it's almost kind of like the
Kareem abdul-jabbar Milwaukee Bucks
story I gave you a championship now
trade me to the Los Angeles Lakers now
LeBron's a free agent so he can kind of
go and pick and choose where he wants if
the money is there but you cannot be
upset at LeBron if he wants to reteam
with dwyane wade in miami i could see
him out here with the Lakers with Kobe
Bryant obviously being gone
I would not be surprised if LeBron goes
somewhere else is it probably highly
unlikely after winning the championship
but there should not be a backlash if
this young man wants to go and play
somewhere else and finish off his career
because he delivered on the ultimate
goal for the Cleveland fans in that area
they want a championship 52 years do you
want a championship so you cannot be
upset if LeBron is thinking about going
elsewhere I don't think it would happen
but as long as he doesn't do the
decision to make it a whole big you know
you know our special again no there
should not be a backlash did Kevin Love
buy more time on this Cleveland team he
did but it will depend on what LeBron
James does if LeBron James if general
manager David Griffin thinks that LeBron
is leaning towards going somewhere else
then you can get something for Kevin
Love and you know you've been hearing
reports of the Boston Celtics have
called his agent and so forth so you can
get something for Kevin Love but if
LeBron is coming back which it's a
better and easier path to the finals who
is in the east is really going to
challenge LeBron Kyrie Tristan Thompson
and Kevin Love yeah that's what I
wondered if if you do leave and you go
to the Western Conference it's tougher
there that if you stay I can't see him
coming to west I would see him stay it's
it easier path to get to the finals and
you don't have to go through a clipper
and okay see if they keep Durant but why
would you play in Miami at Dwyane Wade's
age and you don't even know what's going
on with Chris Bosh well you've got
Winslow perhaps Bosh comes back you got
draaga CH the relationship with Pat
Riley and pie trolley will be very
active in the free agency you know he
liked to keep a winner down there he
still has two home in the Miami area it
would not surprise me hmm I don't see it
happening but you can't be upset after
delivering on your promise anybody in
the dress that you're all in on here
have you seen enough of these guys that
you can say i have um the best talent
what they're saying is the Simmons kid I
to me this I won't say it's going to be
a lot like but this could be like the
Durant versus Odin draft because Ning
gurram to me is a lot like Kevin Durant
can score now his body type is a lot
like Kevin Durant skinny and everyone
saying he's need to put on weight and
he's going to it but I think he's ready
to play right now talent-wise I think
Simmons is the surefire number one but
everything I'm hearing is that he
doesn't even want to work out with the
team to have the overall number one pick
in the Philadelphia 76er well he wants
to go to the Lakers but I everyone wants
to go as a Laker well I think that
they're gonna they're trying to get rid
of DeAngelo Russell but I don't know
who's you know are you gonna be trading
of a first-round pick for DeAngelo
Russell a high first topic would you
yeah I probably would you like a good
tight yeah he has a type of talent would
you rather have Simmons not knowing what
he is or D'Angelo Russell oh right now
I'm going to go with D'Angelo Russell
because I've got a year's a year's worth
of work under his belt now there's other
things that's kind of clouded my
judgment judgment of D'Angelo we all
know what those are but the jump shot
for Vincent is his ? for me oh he's no I
know he does everything else he bound
you know he he can distribute the
basketball he can lead a fast break but
look it he couldn't get his college team
to the postseason that's hard not to do
that's very hard i do right yes in the
SEC you should be able to get there come
on now yeah uh is Brandon Ingram
skinnier than you were coming out of
college I had I have not seen him up
close but from everything because kevin
durant was just as skinny as I was
when I came out of UCLA going to the
Pacers and he's put on I would say what
25 or 30 pounds of muscle maybe yeah but
Brandon Ingram was gonna have to do the
same thing but in terms of footwork
scoring Ingram is my guy yeah jury's
still out you know who I love and
nobody's talking about him the guy that
I know comes in plays right away buddy
hield buddy hield yeah I love him I love
buddy hield go and for your guy I mean
to me it's like the draymond Green
you've seen his body of work for four
years in trust them it's almost a
negative though reg it's like oh but he
went for years it is now but if he in
the right situation in the right team
buddy Hill is going to be a star I just
hope he doesn't end up with Sacramento
cuz that'll be a mess for him well they
gotta figure out what they're gonna do
they do yeah I got oh hello boogie
cousins I like boogie man Sacramento's a
mess they'll be all right there don't
wanna be a mess all right oh hey thanks
as always rich hey it's been a great
year I love coming on this every Monday
or Tuesday and shooting the breeze with
you Theodore my dad asked this is great
I did it's just great I was taking a
shower after a workout at soul cycle and
a guy who was taking a shower and he
came up to me and it's always awkward
with two men when they're naked and and
he says to me hey I'm from San Francisco
I saw your your guy Reggie Miller on the
street and I told him I loved when he
came on the show and I got okay well
thank you so you tell me kind of like
Paulo know you wanted to give me DAP I
said no you're not giving me DAP did you
have teammates who walked around naked
all the time well in the locker room
that's your sanctuary so there a guy
walking all the time naked everywhere
but even when there's people in there
fully clothed they're walking around
naked did you have that yes yes yes who
do you want to again the only people
that are back there or should be back
there our team like your trainers your
doctors now when the media is in there I
bought robes for everyone because we
weren't going to be that team we weren't
going to be disrespectful to the media
so people Rove up robe up who was the
one he had a hard time yeah darn it I am
NOT I thought you were the few guys i
just like to let him hang just like to
let it and that damn rick schmitz the
dunking Dutchman haha they didn't call
him the dunk thanks reg you're the best
hi brother the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience